hello friends and welcome back to rapid
fire language learning today we're
answering the question how to learn a
language at school now most of us if not
all of us have failed to learn a
language at school be it english french
spanish or whatever and the problem is
that we come to the conclusion that it's
us that it's you you're not able to
learn a language but think again it's
not you it's the system that does not
work and with that in mind here's my
piece of advice spend 80 to 90 of your
time learning a language by yourself so
even if you're attending lectures or
you're going to a language school or
you're learning a language in high
school make sure that you spend the bulk
of your time learning by yourself take
initiative do stuff you like and if you
do that then this time that you spend
learning a language in class in the
classroom is even going to become
pleasant if you want to know more about
how to learn a language efficiently
please check out my channel this is it
for now thanks for watching and over and
out